i had a lot of trepidation
about this conference and about my
speaking
i had even a brief moment of hope that
the war would cancel it
because i wasn't sure
what it would be like
to talk to a group of people
while robot bombs are falling on our
enemies around the clock i just couldn't
picture that
so
normally i just sort of take flight and
whatever is on my mind gets splattered
onto your mind
but i don't feel
so certain
of myself
in this situation i'm not sure that just
taking flight for another
evocation
of the psychedelically aided evolution
and transformation of our species
is the way to go
because i think maybe we should
or i should attempt something that's a
little rare for me
plain talk
plain talk
about what's going on
[Music]
yesterday bob wilson got up and talked
about the war and then tim cheered him
on and put his stamp of approval on that
i thought it was great
and then we broke and somebody cornered
me for an interview and they said
what's with these guys dragging politics
into this thing this is not a political
meeting
i was i didn't
say anything i just tried to
[Music]
you know assimilate that and then last
night i thought about it and i've been
thinking about it about this war
about the 60s about vietnam
about how lsd played a major role in
stopping that war by forcing people to
confront what they were really doing by
empowering people to get together in
large groups and say
we won't stand for it we won't put up
with it
and
even though the war is now two weeks old
whatever it is for the first time
really last night
i got
why it feels so bad
to me personally and by extension i
think to all of you
aside from all the horrors of war which
you have had rehearsed for you over the
past two weeks
what really is a pisser
about this
is that it means
for people my age and older
they didn't hear us
we weren't heard
when they were bombing libya we could
just call that an aberration when they
were hunting down noriega we could just
call that a large uh dope bust
this is none of those things this is war
and what we said if you can take
the psychedelic and political struggles
of the 1960s
and boil it down
into one phrase
what did we stand for
we stood for making love
not war
[Applause]
and ever since the the marines were
shoved into the sea at da nang and the
cia was helicoptered off the embassy
roof in saigon
we've been able to hold
a delicate
and very tense balance between the view
of the dominator weapon worshiping old
style macho approach to things and our
own
and i think we all felt
i certainly did last august when they
began to move the chess pieces around
that we would not stand for it that
there was a we
and that we would not stand for it
and if
you were able to keep your idealism
intact until the congressional debate
when you felt then they represent us
they will stop it after all it's the
opposition party to the administration
it's an anti-war party they will stop it
and they went like sheep to the
slaughter
to the slaughter
and they voted for it so now we have no
excuse
no no faction was overridden nobody's
rights were trampled on the path to this
debacle we we the people of the united
states by some staggering percentage
approve
of this
well
so that's
to people like myself and tim leary and
bob wilson and john lilly and all the
people who aren't here and
all of you that i've grown up with and
worked with
this is an abomination
we stand for consciousness expansion
[Music]
do you know
how much you have to have for brains to
wage war
it staggers the imagination
[Applause]
we stood
for um
deconditioning
asking questions
resisting authority
today no questions are being asked
authority is not being resisted oh yes
there are demonstrations against the war
but in a democracy they have what's
called a five percent rule it doesn't
matter if only five percent are involved
in it it doesn't matter what it is so we
have been effectively isolated our names
are uh
have been
metaphorically signed to the bottom line
of these documents that commit us to war
how do you feel
about that
we don't know where we're going we
really don't see light at the end of the
tunnel
this is the surrender issue
it's going to get crazier
the craziness is intensifying
and intensifying
and yet you know we possess
creativity on a scale
undreamed of we can find a way out
there's no problem
we have the technologies
the money
the resources we have everything we need
except
the will
it's a mental quality lacking in us
the will to do it the will to undertake
planetary sized projects
the will to make a plan
that has a 20 year a 50 year and a 500
year benchmark
but we are going to have to very quickly
cease our infantilism
we
need
to eliminate the unconscious mind this
is really what it comes down to folks
we cannot in an era of 30 minute
delivery of thermal nuclear weapons from
anywhere to anywhere we do not have the
luxury of carrying around with us
an enraged
bull
primate
we cannot afford the luxury of the
unconscious the hidden motive the
unexamined drive the misunderstood
acquisition
we are coming now
through a very narrow historical neck
where the accumulated stupidity of the
last five thousand years
is the dues
now have to be paid
it ain't fair
we didn't do it you know we didn't bring
the slaves from africa we didn't invent
oligarchy we didn't do all these things
nobody's interested in our whining about
how we didn't do it
it's in your face
and it's clearly a crisis of
two things of consciousness
and of conditioning
these are the two things that the
psychedelics attack
we
have
the technological power the engineering
skills to save our planet
to cure disease to feed the hungry to
end war
but we
lack
the
intellectual vision
the ability to change our minds
we
must decondition ourselves from 10 000
years of bad behavior
and it's not easy i mean imagine i don't
know how many of you have ever
confronted the fact that you were
addicted to something and some
addictions are really serious if you've
ever been addicted to tobacco or heroin
i'm sure you know what i mean well then
imagine a global population
addicted
to a drug
the use of which is killing us
but we can't there's no there's no
doctor saying you should there's no
rehab clinic to go to when you're a
species we are on an absolutely
destructive bender that will end with
the death of the earth the
impoverishment of its animal and plant
population and the collapse of our
civilization into scarcity unless unless
we can somehow
restructure
our psychology
and and get hold of ourselves and
psychedelics are the only thing i've
ever seen work on an individual level to
do that i can't believe how constipated
american institutions are i mean here we
are under the aegis of a great crusading
reformer from arkansas a new order in
human affairs has dawned but they
suggest closing an air base out at
sacramento
and there are editorials as to whether
we can survive the shock of this massive
change well i've got news for you
you better do your change related
calisthenics if that was heavy lifting
because what you've got coming at you is
is something very very different we are
now in a position to actually um
uh
make something of ourselves extend the
design process to human destiny and
and produce something that will redeem
ten thousand years of pogroms and
migrations and attempted genocides and
pointless wars and stupid religions that
make people hate themselves and all the
rest of it if we're going to redeem that
legacy
then we have to do something quite
spectacular
[Music]
you